okay so just a heads up I lost my voice
earlier so I'm gonna try not to talk too
much a church I keep this under 20
minutes which I yeah he lost his voice
completely but which I feel like we can
do with this we just saw it add for
anyone that wants even more of an
analysis of this if you haven't heard we
are doing a review of this nostalgic
quick review and we're gonna premiere it
on the big screen
pretty sure there's tickets still
available I will put a link down below
so it's in Woodridge Hollywood Boulevard
is a wonderful theater come and see us
we're doing it two nights this time it's
just like Suicide Squad gonna be a lot
of fun blah blah blah that's our ad and
I think we'll definitely get material
out of this yeah you know somebody just
says somebody came up and said did you
like the movie and I said I don't know I
I did the word man wasn't van oh no I
was saying you know it does like it's
not title is IT and I can summon two
letters as well eh yeah but it'd go
three letters and just say it's a little
better and a little worse than I thought
it would be um yeah but maybe not worse
I don't know okay here's the thing if
you're looking for just if you see the
tram when you're like oh that might be
scary good date night movie or something
like that
you'll find it long but you'll probably
get it it has a joke years it has the
sleepy set up to has a clown good cool
when it has enough character development
so you'll get that it's totally fine for
that but in terms of like if you want to
legit like no this is a really really
good movie
it's got good stuff in it got some cool
seeds it's gets into creeps but it's a
total train wreck of not knowing what
the hell it wants to be or who it's even
like and if its target audiences or its
if you dare say that's not you dare say
no ahead a clear identity and knows what
wants to be me no explain to me what the
New Kids on the Block stuff explain to
me the rock fight where this guy's
slo-mo goes you like there's no II
didn't know you didn't sound wrong as we
read where I'm going you know like I'm
with you enough movie but what are you
doing some of these choices are so on
and sometimes it works in its favor it
makes it very funny and goofy whether
it's intentional or not it's very
entertaining but then other times you're
just kind of dragging through stuff
they've either seen before I was over
there are a lot of moments in this movie
where I just was like oh my god will you
just get on with it I didn't get bored
until the last third yes how's that you
and that's the problem like cuz the
movie is such a tonal trainwreck that it
starts a you know and this is a problem
with it I I'm just gonna saying I don't
get the book I there are people who like
it but I know I'm not alone on this
because when I say that people come out
of the woodwork like it's not really one
of kings master books and they're right
it's not really one of kings best book
it much like tries to throw too much and
there is just so he just crammed so much
stuff in it and it all it is is just
like let's answer the question what if
stand by me he had a killer clown like
that so like whenever I think of it
that's the first thing I think it's like
here's this interesting stand by me
story with a whole bunch of drama about
bullying and sexual abuse and getting
over the death of every parent missing
kids yeah and then um
killer clown I just they don't go to get
no no problem let's get right if it was
a killer clown that'd be one thing it's
a killer clown that can also turn into a
mommy away
Vijender other you know and it's it's
throwing too much but at the same time
it's like I think the idea okay this
thing can turn to all your fears it
feeds off your fears it's like okay
there's something there and then like
even when this movie ends it's kind of
like oh yeah there's another movie well
talking about the feeding off your own
fears and your nightmares did you catch
the Nightmare on Elm Street poster in
the background
oh yeah theater yeah I'm just like I
hate it when movies do that sometimes
cuz I just said they're going now to be
fair I'm Reynolds b5 this was 89 it was
supposed to be but it was each one was
five I'm trying I don't know at the
point where they stopped trying but so
that's the problem is like the source
material is part of the problem because
the source material isn't that good so
you've got something that was an 1,100
page like cinder block like paperweight
just jammed full of about ten different
stories yes how supposed to be a lot of
different stories that are somehow
supposed to connect into one story and
now you try to death it into a movie so
you've got the first part which is like
has like all of these things like sexual
abuse and like bullying and all this
stuff each of these kids could have
their own movie the girl in particular
could have our own movie they do that
it's called the horse claim arm but in
every single one these kids can they
have their own movie or it could have
been just about the kids just dealing
with life shit but then you've got some
of the Haunted like the scary stuff and
some of the early stuff is like legit
scary but then in the middle of this
movie I swear to god I'm not making it
up it it I'm not making it oh it turns
into fucking Evil Dead 2 right yeah it's
like movies being bigger like this is
scary this is real this buddy's eyes
Carmen the fat kids belly it's dark it's
dark and then all of a sudden it's like
the clowns and initially the most
cartoonishly ridiculous looking spooky
haunted house like it's literally The
Addams Family house as designed by Tim
Burton like you said it was like Edward
Scissorhands on the inside let me go in
Iowa what
my calling and the weird thing is I have
truly liked better like I feel yeah if
the movement picked a tone and there's
literally a scene where there's three
doors and one says very scary kind of
scary and not scary at all and you have
to open whichever one and I'm like and I
at least one oh no that that was not
scary but it's now on the kid the scene
where the kid goes in the room with all
the clowns and he's just like funny and
then the movie grinds to a halt and like
that is that nothing you need to split
up
yeah the movie like really yeah leave
this split up guy the movie literally
peaked early
it happens to all movies okay if it
climaxed early like right in like at the
2/3 point it's like we're done just all
over us I some like awesome stuff I'm
like alright and I thought they were
gonna end I thought okay maybe they're
gonna wrap this up kind of early and
maybe put some of it but they have a
whole other act and it and it did such a
good job of being strangely entertaining
in the middle in a completely different
way that it is a slog to get through
that last there did it picks it up and
the third does have yeah but there are
actually people floating it should I
always thought in floating in water but
no there's actually people floating well
that brings up a very good point because
Beverly there's this effect where
Beverly is floating and she's going and
it's creating it and it's creepy as fuck
and then there's a scene where all the
kids are floating and they're like going
round this pile of junk and it is the
cheapest lamest CGI effect and I'm
sitting I'm like look at this fucking 20
bucks for like the harness and some wire
or whatever to hoist this girl up and
meanwhile like god knows how many
hundreds of thousands of dollars spent
on this digital effect it looks awful
the simplest effects are the best and
this movie does not get that I'll make a
little bit of an aria
about the times were you know they
really try to have it there and it's
just you know a jump cut away or turn
the camera or something like that there
are times where there was stuff actually
there okay but when he opens the dog
it's like I got big CGI teeth now
there's plenty of times even in that
haunted house scene which you know gets
pretty silly but it's one of those
things where it's like it was going so
cartoony I said okay well that's that's
not there and in a horror movie you have
to what they usually do what they're
finding out more and more is that you
have to have somebody or something
actually there and then you manipulate
the face maybe digitally or something
like that but with the clown to have
them do all these weird things like you
have to contort and turn this way in
what way and stuff like that they had to
use a lot of CG and it was not well done
enough to have me say yes that's really
there when is hand turns into these
claws now that's digital and if you
don't believe it's there why is it scary
yeah and that's it doesn't help to that
like for some reason like we were I was
joking you about this like I like how
Pennywise things that just like doing
this epileptic like kind of like seizure
thing like is like his signature it's
just like I'm gonna scare you with
psychology but at the end this is my
signature
oh it's laughing like yeah I'm just like
what and the sad part is like they're
numerous scenes where the scares being
set up are good there's like a scene
with like a headless kid wandering down
the balcony - that was creepy there's a
scene with a wonderfully sigh yeah I
know the early stuff the early stuff in
this movie for the most part is actually
really good and all some of these pairs
are so brilliantly set up and yeah
deliver exactly how you want it was
great kid
yeah some of these are so this is a
problem this is a problem with the movie
lurches and it's a problem with the book
the clowns a MacGuffin why do you need
the clown okay and here's another one
and Paul ruins he ruins scary that uh-oh
whoa let's finish okay buddies might get
this out of the way because some of
these scares are really good and then
all of a sudden like oh my god that's
terrifying like them clown like it
just doesn't it doesn't work like the
clown actually is the least scary thing
in the movie and just takes you out of
these other legitimate like
psychological like really spooky shit
scares something a lot of people are
saying a lot of critics eliecer saying
is that well penny wise in this he's not
a funny class like Tim Curry he's really
scary this clown is hilarious he is not
as funny as Tim he's not in tendon is
window eyes appears intentionally funny
or not it's actually it's it's hilarious
okay here's the thing and because a lot
of people are going again it's how it is
compared to the original here's the
thing
the original I don't think for an iota I
ever found scary
I find it scary when penny wise isn't
talking but when when he's cracking
jokes no that's not scary but and but
but and a big problem i had when i saw
the trailer for this decided no no
nobody said that the big problem i has
that penny why should he should be a
good clown he should be friendly he
should be like you know hey kids come
into my ice cream truck that's full yeah
I know why then I want to know why
they're any good get close to this clown
they would run around and flee oh and
they try to you bathe a try to go for
the books excuse like but the smell of
peanuts and cotton candy and the sounds
of the circus is being hypnotized but
they don't do that to me or the very end
of a dog and there's one look at that
fucking clown and gone no so but but at
least Tim Curry is a good clown he's a
funny clown this one's funny though I
don't think it was intentional you know
I think it is yeah that's kind of my
guess I do you like jump scares is like
then that's I guess that's scary yeah or
digital felt like like the glowing eyes
and it's like well it did that even felt
like just like we could just do that in
Adobe Premiere and just drew like it's
just here's the thing okay so so curry
and I'm thinking which clown is you know
quote-unquote better
it's like wow okay this one I guess the
movie on the whole had more creeps and
scares and stuff and I thought curry had
a lot more personality if you ask me
personality in this clan I'm like I
don't know just who you know like a baby
that's only thing I can figure like kind
of Tigger and then I realize yes the
thing the original film I felt I should
miniseries I mean this is the first film
we've had of us uh excuse me his first
film had a lot more personality I don't
think it's better I would not even
really say it's good but it had a lot
more personality this one is that a
better idea of what it was yes this one
technically has more scares and it's
more creepy and maybe more character as
more you know and the kids sound a
little bit more like real kids because
they're swearing and stuff like that but
like I said I don't feel it had the
personality the the first one Hanks is
the first one kind of knew what it was
is this corny horror mini-series for TV
you know this one is trying to go balls
to the wall and sometimes it succeeds
and it has a lot of fun but this one's a
bad drama one second and then Evil Dead
to the next I think like was kind of a
mistake putting it in the eighties
they're trying to shoehorn in this 80s
vibe with this kind of eighties humor
and most of it most of it did not work
and yeah even even worse I I'm just
gonna say it I feel I feel sorry for
this director I feel sorry for this for
everyone involved because this is
stranger things and it has nothing to
like this was in production here
coincidence great yeah it's or
coincidence but you cannot unsee it and
the irony of it is stranger things as a
ripoff Stephen King yeah but it's just
like luck of the draw and I think that's
a big problem is this movie even if
stranger things didn't come out this
movie to me feels like at the very least
twenty years to eight like this feels so
tired I say ten oh really I think this
would have worked that well in 2007 I
think was some
scares and the effects and the setup
inside I think I would have worked okay
I think will work fine
it just parts of it still do you know it
just feels so tired the the Stephen King
tropes you know it's like every single
type of loser every single problem you
could have what we're doing plus token
black kid plus like yeah like we have
them plan it it's like you got the most
diverse group and it just it somehow
feels displayed but but you're also
running you one of his most famous
stories that has the most of his tropes
that were the most familiar with I mean
yeah and there are technically some
things and again this is my promise the
source material is it yeah there are
some things they get rid of and they
condense a little bit better but then
some things they don't like okay this
kid gets cut and other kids that go get
medical equipment to tend to his wounds
why why don't you take it to a hospital
no no excellent well could be maybe the
adults you know they're so afraid of the
adults and how everyone's kind of
against them that they they're afraid to
take him to a hospital
maybe that's never explained B while
it's hinted at that if they never fully
you know make that clear and see a it's
just to be a functioning hospital so
they feel like they would still just
some other not sick and they treated
them that that can't be an excuse
there's just some random things to where
it's just like does it movie feel
strangely out of place occasionally like
you'll just do a jump cut to a scene and
you're like how did we get here there
was like no setup for I follow you ended
up in certain sort of scenes all of a
sudden like and now we're here doing
this like there's no establishing
channel it's ironic that this movie is
so long because I felt like with the
exception of the last third I felt like
every scene could use an extra minute
like give us just there an extra may
like the scene with the slides you know
they're setting this up and there's the
sewers in seven they're looking if that
went out a minute longer then when the
slides start playing themselves that
would have been creepier but it happened
too fast and a lot of the scares in the
opening happened too quickly I felt we
need to be at least a minute longer with
these people almost and the promise with
this many characters this is where you
get into trouble which is just as I'm
like oh
well she's got an interesting story
she's being abused or you know this
kid's got an interesting story his
parents died in the fire every time the
foegoer this kids a hide but every time
they're focusing on one and you're just
getting wrapped in it was like no we got
a cutaway clown like well and then we
yes it doesn't like that's it just
doesn't all gel together get two
characters who I'm like you could
totally cut from this movie the
curly-haired kid and the black kid
nothing well what are their
personalities I don't know I mean it's
like one looks he blows the Lambs brain
out at the end yeah I mean it's just he
looks angry and our kids afraid that
that's about it I don't get much else
and that is something where it's like in
the you know the black it comes in much
later in the miniseries but I'm like I
felt like I got more of a personality
out of them in that one and honestly
like I did feel even though I do feel
the comradery here I do feel like these
kids have come together I did feel it
more in the miniseries and I'm wondering
if not just because of the length but
because it cuts to them as adults later
that you do know they come back baby
that time could add to it I'm sure but
bottom line this whole film like I say
if you're just looking for some fast
scares take your date oh yeah totally if
you want the book it's it's a dutiful
recreation to the point that it just
feels like a homework assignment like
here tell me what happened in Stephen
King's it and the director tells you
what happens in Stephen King's Oh like
it's essential treats are good no no
some of us some of the scares are good
but if that's what you want like if you
just want the book then you got it like
and this is for those of you who didn't
like the book I know you're out there
cuz like occasionally you'll like tell
me you're out there like it's just kind
of the book so all the problems that
exist in the book are just on the screen
now like it's weird because it's like
this one is is technically a little bit
more condenses technically a little bit
more scary and has more atmosphere and
stuff like that but there is the first
one does have more personality and
there's some
even though the first is about my
present like more there is so Ganon I'd
like to know this one I'm like I
remember the first one a little more
something this one picked a tone and
stuck with it yeah like at the end when
that kids is like you know I didn't want
to do this anyone come here and now like
and then it's the review again I'm gonna
kill this fucking clown I'm like this is
like Monster Squad yeah and had it had
that tone the whole way through maybe
I'd be like this is amazing but it's
like one third like stand by me meets
Dolores Claiborne meets you know just
dark indie drama me and then comedy yeah
and then meets carnival and evil then -
and then goes back into the dark dress
and then ends on like a monster squad
that it's just all but and I make this
very clear you could love that a part of
me kind of loves that but I don't like
how they didn't mesh they didn't feel
like they fit together here's now cool
pieces but but they didn't quite go oh
no the pieces like those pieces any of
those are fun if they ran with any of
those pieces there at the whole thing it
could have worked like if you want to
make it scary because that first part
like that that fucking library scene was
chilling I'm just like whoa um I've left
the scene with a that referenced the
kids parents with all the hands coming
out of the fire was also - it all those
scenes are chilling like in the hand
they still stuck with that dark tone but
then this is also problem of the source
material at any point no matter how dark
and really creepy and chilling it gets
it always ends with clown like and I
just don't find the clown scary's I will
say if people because this is getting
good reviews and I feel like there are
no I feel like there are a lot of people
are gonna like this I it's not like it's
not like the original it where I'm so
surprised people were scared by this
where I would just growing up I would be
like how are you scared of this I don't
understand this one at least I can
understand I get and get decent reviews
its the reviews though that are just
like oh my god this is one of the most
amazing films I'm like really a lie I
don't know if you seen that I know I've
seen a few go toes
I've definitely
a couple I really like it the one that
liked it a lot honestly um and like I
said but parts I kind of get I mean like
there is a lot of stuff that's fun about
it but the parts that are really creepy
are really good but then there's just so
many just like hope you like rote jump
scares and loud noises cuz like for as
many great scares as there are in this
50% of them are just like the movie
you know those numbers they like just
stick to your head like I'm Fear Factor
or whatever and everything else moves
already but the head is still they do
that a lot with the clown and it's
really fake and not in the movie lost me
almost instantly because they send
Georgy down into the basement and it's
like whoo it's creepy down music yeah
and then like his brother stalks him on
the walkie-talkie and it's insane that
the loudest fucking walkie-talkie yeah
and it's insanely loud it's like whop
there's a drum scare and then he turns
around and then there's like two little
beady like it's a digital effect like
two little beady eyes like shitting I'm
like well there's another jump scare
than any flips I was like oh it's just a
couple of light bulbs I'm like Jesus
Christ like it's like already we're like
falling on these cliches and we're
really 40 seconds into the credits
aren't even done you're not gonna kill
me well before the credits are done yeah
if we also you're gonna read and I
pretty much the most famous scene from
the movie and what we know the kids not
gonna get it yet so yeah it's just in
those kind of things like really bombing
because I'm like you're wasting my time
this is a waste of my time
I know exactly everybody knows that
scene that every it's just get to it why
are you wasting it on a fake scare yeah
either give us some setup with the
characters or you know just get to what
everybody knows is coming but a lot of
the scares for as many that are so good
a lot of the scares are like that and it
just I just just so bored threw out
chunks of this movie and and yet I was
simultaneously at certain points
immensely entertained hmm
there you have it half
this movie yeah because I don't regret
see you know my wife wants to go see it
I'll go see you with her I'll see you
there um you know because I'm gonna do a
listing of it but yeah there's there's
plenty of stuff to to talk about it I'm
actually curious what people think of it
I got a feeling a lot of people are
gonna like this film they're gonna get
really really into it um but I'm very
much down the middle just half and half
I just once again much like the book by
the time it was done I was like scariest
thing in the whole fucking thing was the
humans yeah like scary scene in the
movie is with it's like let's shoot the
cat I was like Jesus Christ you know you
know there is a seem like that there is
another before I forget that that was
one of the examples I was talking about
the one man however seen before the last
third need one more minute that scene
with the father come in taking the
Ganesha he came in way too fast no no no
no no no Bob Santa but but they also
found a minik you imagined that minute
taken out it just the bully goes after
the kids again it would have meant
nothing bo this kid again but knowing
that made a big difference I feel like
just those just say extra know it and
that was one addictive but it was also
then done that was like that was a lot
scarier then yeah they've got a clown on
a stage in the background that's got
this weird evil smile on like that clown
scares what we got the room full of fake
clowns was scary that I'm sorry I just
I'm not into the clown like this was my
problem with the with the source
material in the film both it's just like
you did the clowns of MacGuffin you
don't need the clown I like the did did
you like the glowing eyes in the drain
and I thought that was pretty cool well
when he's in the sewer very effective
but yeah so there you go I like I said I
think you can get an idea whether or not
you just want you know a goofy movie boy
a scary movie with some booze and a
little bit of character and stuff it's
fine if you want the definitive it book
yeah half and half but again we can't we
can't think the same thing about all
those anyway it follows the book pretty
close like yeah oh they took some of the
more offensive bits are bits like bears
in the jaw
gangbang like it wasn't gonna be in
there anyway like that's I think that's
a good cut
I get occasion some people like I can't
believe they took that out it's all you
really can't believe that but it yeah
it's just it's the book I mean if you
like the book and you just want kind of
a very buy than paint-by-number kind of
interpretation in the book there you go
that should give you a general general
idea there I my voices go what did you
get here so ah we better cut it off here
so yeah go take a look tell us what you
think and be sure to check out our
review and establish a ween it's there's
definitely stuff to talk about so we
will see you then
[Music]
you